et on en parlait en début d'émission le
groupe L'Oréal organise depuis plus de
30 ans un concours mondial d'innovation
ce concours met en compétition des
candidats du monde entier pour proposer
des innovations de demain dans le
secteur de la beauté et Marie landrevy
vous y participer avec votre équipe vous
avez proposé you are modèle donc c'est
une technologie qui utilise
l'intelligence artificielle et elle
permet donc à un utilisateur de plaudé
une photo de lui sur un site e-commerce
et de pouvoir tester les produits
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez décidé de
lancer de vous lancer sur ce projet
alors donc déjà il faut savoir que la
compétition du Lorraine one sound c'est
une conviction qui est assez connue donc
en école de commerce parce qu'on est
toutes les trois donc Sophie Martinez
pierre on est tous les trois à sec donc
c'est une compétition qui est assez
connue et qu'on aime bien faire parce
que c'est challengeance et toujours
voilà histoire de repousser ses limites
donc on nous a proposé une problématique
qui était de donc de créer une
expérience consommateur
donc pour L'Oréal en utilisant les
technologies du web 3 donc ça va être la
réalité augmentée l'intelligence
artificielle le méta verse etc et donc
c'était très large et c'était à nous en
fait de d'un peu de de créer notre
propre problématique et donc on a
vraiment essayé de trouver un sujet qui
nous tenait à coeur et qui pour nous
était vraiment important donc on a
vraiment on a vraiment cherché ensemble
et donc on a décidé de de toucher à
l'inclusivité donc un gros problème pour
nous c'est que même si voilà les
couleurs de peau etc sont de plus en
plus représentées pour nous en fait il
faut aller encore un pas plus loin voire
même deux voire même trois donc arriver
en fait c'est de voilà de de surpasser
l'utilisation des mannequins et que le
consommateur devienne en fait le
mannequin donc pour ses yeux seulement
mais voilà plus se sentir représenté
parce qu'en fait on s'est dit la
meilleure façon de se sentir représenté
de se sentir représenté pardon c'est de
se voir soi-même donc donc voilà on a
ici on a essayé de développer un peu une
technologie pour pour répondre à ce
problème et donc c'est quelque chose qui
vous intéressait vous plus
particulièrement est-ce que c'est aussi
quelque chose qui était intégré dans
votre programme scolaire ou pas du tout
alors ça a été intégré dans notre
programme scolaire on a eu donc on a une
compétition qui s'appelle la Digital
week elle est sec ou on a pu travailler
pour L'Oréal travailler c'est un très
grand mot mais on a pu faire un projet
pour L'Oréal et donc il nous avait
proposé une problématique assez
similaire et ensuite ils nous ont
encouragé à pousser notre projet donc le
présenter sur cette compétition
internationale ce qu'on a fait parce
qu'on a été hyper motivé on a adoré
l'expérience donc on a voulu pour suivre
et justement ce concept des sièges
virtuels il existe déjà on a pu le voir
notamment avec modify pourquoi enfin
qu'est ce qui fait l'originalité
finalement de votre projet aujourd'hui
alors du coup modify pour ceux qui
connaissent un peu moins en fait c'est
du virtual soyons donc quand on va sur
un site internet maintenant on a la
chance de pouvoir voilà essayer avec sa
caméra et voir un peu ce que le produit
pourrait ressembler sur sur notre visage
après c'est assez limite c'est à dire
que quand on voilà quand on est sur le
site internet de Maybelline bah parfois
on est dans le train parfois on est dans
son lit et donc bah voilà tout le tout
le background la luminosité est pas
forcément optimale et donc parfois ça
peut donner un contenu qui est pas
forcément très représentatif de la
réalité ou très professionnel et en plus
de ça il faut prendre une photo ou un
scanner à chaque fois qu'on veut aussi
un nouveau produit et donc nous on veut
vraiment proposer une expérience 360 qui
s'arrête jamais on veut voilà un scan du
visage et tout le site le site internet
se synchronise pour que le visage du
consommateur apparaissent sur les pages
produits donc avec les angles parfaits
la luminosité parfaite pour vraiment
avoir un contenu professionnel et hyper
représentatif de la réalité et du coup
ça sera utilisable sur le site de
L'Oréal puisque il y aura aussi d'autres
marques qui pourront utiliser ça ou
alors du coup notre projet pour
l'instant on est parti sur la marque
maybuline évidemment c'est qu'un projet
c'est une proposition donc on est parti
sur la marque Maybelline qui fait
beaucoup de make-up et qui cible surtout
les les jeunes aides parce qu'on s'est
dit que potentiellement c'était une
technologie qui pouvait peut-être les
mettre plus à l'aise et que voilà une
tranche une tranche de population
peut-être un peu moins à l'aise avec la
technologie etc après évidemment le but
c'est que voilà nous on veut vraiment
pousser le projet le plus loin possible
on pense que ça a vraiment un bon fond
et que ça peut vraiment avoir un impact
positif donc l'objectif c'est vraiment
de mettre tout le monde à l'aise avec
donc notre technologie you are modèle
pour que tout le monde puisse l'utiliser
au final alors du coup là donc vous êtes
dans ce concours quels sont justement
les prochaines étapes alors du coup là
on a eu donc la compétition je pense
qu'on a remporté donc là on monte dans
la compétition monde donc là dans
quelques jours on va passer la
demi-finale on aura les résultats il me
semble le 16 mai ensuite il y a la
finale qui se tient à Viva technology
donc via technologie c'est un c'est un
festival de technologie c'est un des
plus grands d'Europe qui se tient on a
la chance qui tiennent à Paris et donc
si on passe en finale on devrait pitcher
donc notre projet devant tous les
membres et les visiteurs de Viva
technologie et donc ça ça se tient en
juin et justement vous êtes dans quel
état d'esprit aujourd'hui bah je pense
que ça fait un moment qu'on travaille
dessus et c'est vraiment un projet qui
nous tient à cœur parce que comme je
vous l'ai dit on croit vraiment que ça
peut plus que voilà permettre à L'Oréal
ou à une marque de
convaincre ses consommateurs on pense
vraiment que c'est un bon fond et que ça
peut vraiment faire du bien donc ça nous
tient vraiment à coeur donc on espère
aller plus loin possible et on se donne
vraiment les moyens on profite de de
toutes les opportunités et les
ressources que nous donnent L'Oréal pour
avancer sur notre projet qui sont
vraiment qui sont vraiment très utiles
et on croise les doigts pour pour les
prochaines étapes mais en tout cas on
croise tous les doigts pour vous merci
Marie landrevy de nous avoir présenté
votre projet on vous souhaite d'aller
justement au bout de ce concours
concours qui je le rappelle annoncera
les 10 derniers finalistes le 12 mai
prochain